[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU:
Thank you so much.
Hello, Google.
Afternoon.
I'm so happy to be here.
It is my fourth visit,
I think, as you said,
first time in New
York City for Google.
And just trying to
figure out how many
Google locations there are.
You helped me before.
I think you said there's 70
locations in 40 countries.
AUDIENCE: That's
according to Google.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU:
According to Google.
I mean, it's a
verifiable good source.
So after I finished going to
every country in the world,
I was like, maybe
I need a new quest,
and maybe now I'll try to
go to every Google office.
Did San Francisco, Mountain
View, Dublin, now here.
Super excited to be here.
I would love to share
a few stories with you.
I'll give you four tips, four
actionable things that you
can do right away,
tonight, tomorrow
to make real improvements
in your life and work.
And then we'll have
a conversation.
Love to have some questions
and attempted answers,
and we will hang out.
So everything I do is focused
more or less around this topic
of how to find the
work you were born
to do, how to find that thing
that makes you come alive,
that thing you can kind
of lose yourself in,
but it's also sustainable,
something you enjoy,
something that is
financially viable,
and something that
you're really good at.
And I'll talk about
that as we go along.
But first I have a
question for some of you.
Do you remember when
you were six years old
and some adult, maybe a
friend of your parents,
random stranger,
teacher, asked you
this question, what do you
want to be when you grow up?
How many of you remember
your answer to that?
Raise your hand.
Andrew, what was your answer?
ANDREW: I wanted to be a pilot.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU:
Wanted to be a pilot.
Did you grow up
to become a pilot?
AUDIENCE: No.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: No.
What was your answer?
AUDIENCE: Same.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Same.
Also a pilot.
Two pilots in the front row.
That's awesome.
What was your answer?
AUDIENCE: I wanted to be rich.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: You
wanted to be rich.
OK.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: Firefighter.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Firefighter.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I fight
different kinds of fires.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: You fight
OK.
Anybody else?
Yeah.
Over there?
AUDIENCE: Psychologist.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Psychologist.
Why did you want to be a
psychologist when you were six?
AUDIENCE: Because I like
to read people's minds.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: OK.
You like to read people's minds.
Couple of other people.
Raise your hand.
Yeah, all the way in the back.
A pilot.
OK.
This is a high pilot
audience here at Google,
which I suppose makes sense.
And maybe one more person.
Is there anyone who
wanted to do something
totally wild and crazy?
You had your hand up
and you put it down.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
be a fashion designer.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: That's cool.
AUDIENCE: A wild and
crazy fashion designer.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU:
Did you grow up
to become a wild and
crazy fashion designer?
And then lastly you had your
hand raised as well, I think?
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to be the president.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: You
wanted to be the president.
All right.
Well, there's still time.
OK.
So last question.
Who here is doing exactly
what they imagined
when they were six years old?
Is there anyone?
You kind of have your
hand, like, halfway up.
Did you become a psychologist?
AUDIENCE: No, but I still
read people's minds.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: You
still read people's minds.
OK.
And are you rich yet?
Still working on it?
OK.
Awesome.
So the interesting
thing, the curious thing,
is that most of
us actually do not
know when we're six years
old, like, what we're
going to be when we grow up.
Hello, everyone.
Good to see you guys.
This is my team from
Crown Random House.
Big part of making
the book happen.
So thank you guys for coming.
and just a little bit
briefly about my journey.
When I was six, I
had twin aspirations.
There were two things
that I wanted to do.
Did anyone want to
be an astronaut?
People usually say that.
Everybody here
wanted to be a pilot.
We had three people
here who said
they wanted to be a pilot
when they were six years old.
So my dad worked for NASA.
And when I was six years old
he took me to his office.
And there was a special
lunch happening.
And he gave me a task.
He gave me an assignment.
And now kind of
looking back, I can
see it was a fake assignment,
like a manufactured
kind of thing.
But at the age of six, I
thought I was singlehandedly
responsible for the safety and
success of the space shuttle
launch.
And so I completed my
task with diligence.
Everything was good
for the launch.
And then we went to my
favorite restaurant,
which was Burger King.
So when I was six
years old, Burger King
was like the greatest
place in the world.
And if it was my
birthday or if I had just
saved the world, sent
the shuttle into space
successfully, or if it was
Monday or Tuesday or pretty
much any other
day, I would always
want to go to Burger King.
And so when people
ask me, what do
you want to be when you grow
up, Chris, I would either say,
I want to be an astronaut or
I want to work at Burger King.
And the thing is I didn't
really know the difference
at the age of six.
At the age of six
it was just like,
these are too cool places.
These are two
really cool things.
And I didn't understand there's
actually a lot of differences
here in terms of what
that career track is like,
and advancement potential,
and compensation, and lots
of other things.
I just knew it was these two
interesting things, right?
And so I grew up, and
I wasn't smart enough
to work for NASA--
or Google, I should
say-- but at a certain
point, I realized
that a career in fast
food probably wasn't
the best choice for me either.
And so I did a lot
different things.
I started a series
of small businesses.
I always worked
for myself, mostly
because I wasn't that good
at working for other people.
I was very motivated in doing
something that I believed in,
but it was kind of hard
for me to do something that
wasn't my vision or my idea.
And started traveling
at a certain point.
I lived in Sierra
Leone and Liberia
for about four years as an aid
worker after a civil war there.
And started going to
lots of other countries.
And then, as you
heard, eventually
started this travel
quest of going
to every country in
the world, which was
about a 10- or 11-year journey.
At a certain point, I started
writing about it on the blog
The Art Of Nonconformity,
and eventually the books.
And as part of this
whole process--
wasn't really
strategic, it was just
much more of an
organic thing-- but as
part of this process, everything
I do now, one way or another,
is kind of focused on this
aspect of community building.
And when I say
community building,
it's not so much a top
down kind of thing.
It's not so much about me giving
people tools and resources
as it is about bringing
like-minded people together,
forging connections,
and kind of seeing
how we can support one another.
So I'm really interested
in this convergence
between a big dream,
like following
a big dream or a
passion of your own,
like mine was to go to
every country in the world,
and also contributing
something, some act of service.
So I like to kind of bring
people together and support
them in their quest as well.
So this was kind of a
long and winding road.
It wasn't a strategy.
And your journey was
probably different from mine.
But you, too, had
to make choices,
and you, too, had
to make decisions.
And many of you are
probably still making
decisions at different times.
And we kind of go through life
and we navigate this process
with limited information.
So we don't actually know what
everything is going to be like.
We have to make
these decisions that
are going to set
things in motion
for several years
or even longer.
And we often make these
decisions under what
I call a haze of uncertainty.
So it's like, well, I think I
know what it's like to do this,
and maybe I'm good at this.
Maybe I took a skills test,
or maybe my guidance counselor
suggested this to me.
Or maybe I had a
friend who did this.
But I don't really know
until I start doing it.
I don't really know
until I actually
start going down that road.
And so what a lot
of us end up doing,
or at least what a lot
of people end up doing,
is settling, or making
some kind of compromise.
And we all have to make
compromises in life.
But this is kind of a central
compromise of saying, like,
OK, I'm going to either choose
between work that I really
love, or a life that
I love, and the job
is going to be kind
of a means to an end,
but I'm not going to be
able to do both things.
I'm either going to have the
job as a means to an end,
or I'm going to pursue
something I love but I'm
going to be poor, et cetera.
And that's not really the goal.
I mean, obviously, Googlers
interested in self-improvement,
interested in
continuous improvement.
The goal is essentially to have
both, your money and your life,
and also one more
thing that I'll
tell you about in a moment.
But first, I talked about
this non-linear journey
that I went on.
And over the past
three years I've
been looking at people from
all different walks of life
who have found or created what
they call their dream job.
And I kind of wanted to extract,
what are the commonalities
of these people?
Because they're very
different in some ways.
We did this comprehensive
research study.
We looked at men and women,
different backgrounds,
different ages, different
kinds of careers.
What do they have in common?
And one thing I saw
almost immediately
is that almost none of
them follow a linear path.
Almost all of them have this
kind of long and winding road.
Almost all of them go
down different paths.
And then they
aren't afraid-- this
is a key point-- they aren't
afraid to kind of go down
a path for awhile and
take a step back and say,
actually, I thought
this was good,
but I'm actually do
something different.
So there's this old poem
about the road not taken
by Robert Frost, how
two roads diverge
in a woods and the traveler
has to make a choice.
Do I go down this road,
do I go down that one?
In that poem, he
says, you know, I
chose the road less
traveled by, and that
has made all the difference.
So one way to think
of that is, OK, he
chose the right road, right?
That road made all the
difference, that choice.
But what we don't know is
what was down the other road.
What was the other path?
What was that story?
And maybe that path was
just as good, right?
Maybe that path was even better.
We just don't know
because we don't know
the other part of the story.
So I saw that these people who
identified with his dream job
concept, they
talked about things
like, I would go to work even
if I didn't get paid for it.
That's how much I believe in it.
But thankfully I
do get paid for it.
Hopefully maybe some of you
could say that same thing.
But what I saw is that
not only do they go down
a lot of different
paths, they also
weren't afraid to make mistakes.
And when they made
mistakes, it wasn't
just that the mistakes were OK.
It wasn't that it just
turned out all right.
It was actually
that the mistakes
could be beneficial
for them, because they
made decisions, like all of us
do, with limited information.
And as they went
down different paths
and sometimes made mistakes,
sometimes had success,
all of these things gave
them more information
to make better decisions
as they went along.
So I thought that
was interesting.
One of the people I
looked at it in the book
was a successful working actor.
She had done a lot of regional
theater across the country.
She had been on
several TV shows.
And then she kind of
went down a winding road
to make a career change.
She said acting was good, but
she wanted something different.
And I really like this quote.
She said she was kind of
going in search of something.
She didn't really
even know what it was.
But she didn't find it
through a eureka moment.
It was a process
of discovery that
led her to something that
provided the autonomy that she
craved.
So it was a very
values-based journey.
It wasn't like, here's my goal.
What do I need to do
to make that happen?
It was, here's my value,
autonomy, freedom,
independence.
I want the ability to choose.
And that kind of led
her along the way.
Lots of different
twists and turns
before she found something
that she liked even better.
So even though people want to
do a lot of different things,
different professions and
vocations, most of us,
if we're on this kind of
course for a dream job,
there are three qualities
that every dream job has.
This is true in
entrepreneurship.
This is true if you're
working for a company, people
working in non-profits.
Everybody who's
really successful--
and when I say successful,
I mean your own definition
of success, whatever
success means to you.
It can mean different
things to different people.
But let's say purposeful,
let's say fulfilled.
They all have this
quality of joy.
They're doing something
that they love to do.
It's not quite like
following your passion.
It's doing something
that you love,
and it also integrates
with other qualities.
Second quality is what I
mentioned before, money.
Something that is
financially viable,
something that is sustainable.
And the third quality is
flow, or essentially something
that you do really
well, something
that uses your skills in a
unique way, the kind of work
that you can really
get lost in, the kind
of work that makes you come
alive, the kind of thing
you do where you're like,
the hours kind of go by
and I don't really see where
they went because I was so
immersed in this thing.
So I like what I do,
it's sustainable,
and I'm actually doing
something I'm really good at.
And people who are
successful-- again,
by your own
definition, people who
are purposeful-- they work
toward the intersection
of all three of these qualities.
They work to find not just
one of them, not just two,
but actually all three.
And if we think about people
who are really successful--
maybe even some famous people.
We can kind of look
from the outside
and say, OK, they're
clearly doing
what they were born to do.
Maybe there's more
than one path.
Maybe they could have done
something different themselves.
But they didn't.
Beyonce could have
been a dentist,
could've been an accountant.
Roger Federer could have been
a Swiss watchmaker or something
else.
And that might have been
fine, but not necessarily
the work they were born
to do, not necessarily
the pinnacle of a career or a
whole industry, where all of us
can look at them
and say, clearly
doing something that's
amazing and fantastic and very
fulfilling.
And it's not just
about celebrities.
You can probably think
of someone that you know.
My editor Talia Krohn is
here from Random House.
She gave me this great example
that we use in the book.
She said, you know,
it's almost like
when you run into somebody that
you knew back in high school
and you haven't
kept up with them.
So five years go by, 10
years, 20 years whatever.
And you run into them and you
hear what they're doing now.
And you're like, that
makes perfect sense.
I can look back to them
when they were teenagers
or young, whatever, and
I can see these traits
that were in their life.
And now I can see, of
course she became a doctor.
Of course he became an engineer.
Makes perfect sense.
That's totally the work
that they were born to do.
They've work closely to get
close to the intersection
of joy, money, and flow.
And the second big
lesson, second thing
that kind of emerged
through all the research,
is it's not just about
the kind of profession
we hold, the kind of
vocation, what we actually do,
that leads to success
and happiness.
It's the working environment
or the working conditions.
It's actually how
we do our work that
is just as important as the
content or the type of work.
And this is really
critical, because almost
all career-based education,
almost all skill training,
focuses on vocation
or on profession,
like here's the ideal
profession for you.
When you're six years
old, what do you
want to be when you grow up?
And we identify professions.
When you're going
to go and study,
I'm going to choose
the field of study that
leads to a certain profession.
If you're a bit
older, then you're
going to take on a second
act or a third act,
do something different.
You're always thinking
in terms of professions.
But what's just as important
is to understand, OK,
how do I do my ideal work?
And how can I create
the conditions
that work best for me?
So working conditions
are things like how
you like to spend your time,
your ideal schedule, where you
like to do your work, how you
like to be rewarded, motivated,
compensated-- it's different
for different people--
how collaborative you
are, how much you like
to work with other people
versus how much you
like to work on your own.
Pretty much all of us like to
do some of both of those things.
But the range is tremendous.
Some people really want much
more of a social structure.
Some people really want
much more independent time
to carve out and
create something.
So all these different factors
that are working conditions
that lead to the environment in
which we do our best work or we
don't, in which we feel
supported or we don't.
And the goal is to find
the right kind of work
in the right kind of
working conditions, which
is very individual.
What we're looking for,
right kind of work,
right kind of
working conditions.
If you have a job that
you believe in-- good job,
you like what you do--
but the conditions are not
good for you, you have a
boss that's overly negative,
you have a conflict with
one of your colleagues,
the schedule doesn't
work for your needs--
it's going to be stressful.
It doesn't matter
that it's a good job.
You're going to be
stressed in that situation.
On the other hand, you could
have really good working
conditions, you could have
the best possible environment,
but if you're not actually doing
something that you believe in,
then you're going
to be unfulfilled.
You're going to
look and say, OK,
I have this good environment,
but I'm not actually
part of something that's
bigger than myself.
I don't believe in this mission.
It's fine for a while, but
it's not actually really making
me feel purposeful.
So the goal is,
right kind of work,
right kind of
working conditions,
engaging content,
good conditions.
If you're try to
figure out, OK, what
are my ideal working
conditions, then you
can go to the website
bornforthisbook.com.
You can take a free quiz.
You don't have to
register or anything.
You're going to
answer 14 questions
and it's going to give you
a very specific personality
type along with some clear
recommendations and strategies
for you.
This isn't going to tell
you to change your job.
It's going to tell you
how to adapt your working
conditions and the kind of
work, the kind of environment
under which you'll thrive.
So I said I'll give you four
actions, four specific things
you can do today,
tomorrow, going forward.
First thing is, we talked
about this model of joy, money,
and flow, the three qualities
of any successful dream
job, anyone who feels like
they've won the career lottery.
And as much as possible,
wherever you can make decisions
based on this
model, big decision,
small decisions, the
happier you will be.
I understand that not
everybody-- almost no one-- has
100% autonomy over their time.
Even if you're
completely self-employed
you don't have 100% autonomy.
But wherever you
do have autonomy,
wherever you can make
choice, you think about this.
You think about what I
love to do, what is viable,
and what I'm really good at.
Here's a very simple thing.
All of you can do this.
I try to answer this
question every day.
At the end of the day,
I take out my journal,
or if you're not a
journaling person,
you can use a Post-It note.
You probably do it digitally.
And you answer this
question, did today matter?
And I believe when all
of us do that, we're
going to know the
answer to that question.
You answer it in your own way
based on your own evaluation,
based on your own standard,
what you think success to be.
And I think if you look
back, you'll be able to say,
OK, today I actually made
progress on my goals.
I got a little bit closer to
that thing I'm working toward.
I also was in good
harmony with people.
I invested in the relationships
that are important to me.
Good day.
Today mattered.
Or you might look back and say,
actually, it wasn't that great.
It started kind of poorly.
There was some problem
or some conflict.
Then I just behind, I was just
responding to things all day.
I didn't really create anything.
Like I was at work
for all this time
but I don't actually
know what I did.
All of us have bad
days, like that happens.
But the goal, the goal is a
streak of days that matter.
The goal is being able
to say over and over,
yes, you know, today mattered.
Maybe it had some challenge.
Maybe it had some problem.
There was some obstacle.
It wasn't perfect,
but today mattered.
And when we answer
that question,
we're going to begin to
identify over and over,
what are the qualities
that lead us to say,
OK, today was a
day that mattered?
And we're going to do more
and more of those things.
What are the activities
that gave me energy today?
that drained my energy?
How can I do more
of those things
wherever I do have a choice?
Second recommendation that
I've been talking with people
about all over the
country-- and I'll
be very careful in talking
about it here-- is I
have seen over and over that
wherever people are employed,
even when they
love their job, it
can be tremendously empowering
for them to have something
on the side that they do,
some kind of side business,
some kind of additional project.
Even if it's not
something that is bringing
in a tremendous
amount of money, it
can be disproportionately
satisfying
and disproportionately
rewarding.
I get emails all the
time from people who say,
I was never an entrepreneur.
I don't even want to
be an entrepreneur.
I'm not sure that's my thing.
So I started this little
project, or I made some arts
and crafts and I
sold them on Etsy.
Or I started this
consulting thing that
has nothing to do with my job.
There's no conflicts.
I just do it on the
weekend or something.
But I signed my first client.
It was fantastic.
So in the book I have a
number of stories about this.
Some of them are like
this guy, Benny Shu,
from Jacksonville,
Florida, who had started
a bunch of different projects.
And some of them kind of
took off and some of them
didn't, which is totally normal.
But eventually he got a
project designing t-shirts
and selling them through online
ads on Google and Facebook.
And within a year he
was earning more money
from that side business than
he was in his day job as an app
developer.
So in his case, he did quit
his job and go kind of full
into that project.
I also hear from people
who have a side hustle
and kind of build that out,
and it becomes successful.
And then they have
to make a choice.
OK, I do I do that or do I
kind of remain with my job?
And sometimes people choose
to stay with their job.
And they say, actually,
I like the side project,
but the kind of work
that I'm doing in my job
is very different, and I
have a different environment
and I'm working
with people I like,
and I'm going to
keep doing that.
And I think that's a great place
to be as well, because when
you have the other thing
and it's going well,
you don't have to go to work.
You're going to work every day
because you want to go to work,
not because you have to.
And I think that's
an ideal situation
not just for an employee,
but also for an employer,
to have their people coming
to work because they want
to be there,
because they believe
in the value of the mission.
People often talk about, how
do I find the time to do this?
And what I always
say to people when
I'm speaking to other audiences
is, well, we're all busy.
Everybody has lots
of commitments.
But when you're
busy, in some cases
that can be a benefit,
because you have limited time.
You have to make
that time count.
You don't have 40,
50 hours open to you.
You can't be on 12
different social networks.
You can't start a whole
bunch of different things.
You've got to focus on
the things that matter.
And there's some more
information on that
if you go to the website
and register the book.
Third recommendation.
If you already know, I am
expert in this one thing,
and I'm a specialized
expert, I know more
about this than anybody
else, that's great.
That's wonderful.
But a lot of people,
even in companies,
even in technical careers,
feel this pressure
to know what that thing is.
And they don't always know
because they haven't gone down
enough roads.
They don't have
enough experience.
And maybe even if
they've gone down roads,
maybe there's something
else out there.
So you don't have
to choose a niche.
And I've seen lots
of successful people
who've been able to kind
of craft a career in more
than one interest.
And sometimes they're
focused, and sometimes they've
actually been able
to choose a direction
and combine two or
three different things.
We can look at some celebrities
again, just briefly.
Richard Branson started more
than 80 different companies
across a range of industries.
Record label, airline, soda
company, cosmetics, fashion,
newspapers, magazines.
His first business was actually
selling Christmas trees.
I don't know how many
people knew that.
Probably no one, because
it wasn't successful.
It's kind of a
seasonal business.
But all these
different businesses
weren't really linked,
by industry, at least.
It was a very
values-guided business,
just like Laura's approach
to finding her ideal career
was a values-based journey.
Oprah has influenced millions
of people all over the world
and has been a leader in
media, entertainment, but also
business, spirituality,
wellness, self-care,
all kinds of different things.
She's very good
at what she does,
but it wasn't just one thing.
She kind of honed a career
around multiple interests
and multiple focuses.
And so you, too-- just
as we said earlier--
you can probably think of
someone else that you know.
It's not just about
celebrities or famous people.
You can probably
think of someone
that you know who
has been able to be
successful without focusing on
one hyper-specialized, focused
thing.
You don't have to
choose a niche.
And here's my last
recommendation.
If something isn't working
in your life or your work,
I think you should
stop doing it.
And we are told over and over
in this entrepreneurial age
we live in, which has lots
of good qualities in it--
but in particular the western
mindset of manifest destiny
and pioneering-- has this
belief that winners never quit.
And what I saw through
all my research
and talking with lots
of different people
is that winners
quit all the time.
Winners aren't afraid to
walk away from something.
Winners aren't afraid to say,
I actually went down this path
and it wasn't the right path.
Or maybe it was the
right path for a time,
but now I want
something different.
I'm going to change it up.
So part of the
conventional wisdom,
especially in terms of careers
and business education--
conventional wisdom, you've
probably heard this--
is that persistence is the most
important predictor of success.
And I don't think that's true.
I think that flexibility
and adaptation
are the most important
predictors of success,
being willing to
kind of change it up.
So here's one story
to illustrate this.
This is a story called
"Three Feet from Gold."
In 1851, California
Gold Rush, a prospector
moves across the country and
buys a small plot of land.
And every day for
weeks, months, years,
some long period of time,
he's panning for gold.
And he's unsuccessful.
Every day no gold, kind of
running out his life savings.
So finally one day, he
sells the plot of land
to somebody else for a
small amount of money.
And the very next day after
that the new guy strikes gold
just three feet from where
the first guy gave up.
So the way this
story is always told,
the lesson is, first
guy gave up too soon.
If only he had kept going.
And this story,
or even this myth,
is kind of perpetrated in
all kinds of success stories
that we hear about someone who
fails 10 times, 25 times, et
cetera, only to succeed
on the 26th time.
So the lesson is, first guy
shouldn't have given up.
Even back in 1851 this was
a popular meme on Snapchat
getting lots of views.
Everybody was like, first guy
shouldn't have abandoned ship.
But just like we don't know
what would have happened
on that other path we started
with in the beginning,
we don't know what happened
with the first prospector.
First of all, there
was no guarantee
he was going to strike it rich.
It's actually quite likely
that he wouldn't because he
had done it over and over.
He was doing the same thing.
He wasn't getting
different results.
And secondly, we don't know
what he did after that,
after he sold the plot of land.
Maybe he went on
to a better life.
Maybe he found a different path.
Maybe started a
shovel-selling business
for all the other prospectors
who were heading west.
And so I don't think you should
give up on your life dream.
I don't think you should give
up on your ultimate vision.
But I think the best lesson is,
you should always keep trying,
but you should try again
in a different way,
and you shouldn't
try the same thing.
And if something
isn't working, then
don't be afraid to give up.
How many of you have
bought a lottery
ticket in the past few months,
let's say, past three months?
Andrew, why'd you buy
the lottery ticket?
ANDREW: Because the jackpot
was, like, a billion dollars.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU:
Because the jackpot was,
like, a billion dollars.
That's right.
Why'd you buy-- because
you wanted to be rich.
You said that earlier.
Did it work out?
AUDIENCE: Nope.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: OK.
Anybody else?
Any other reason for
buying a lottery ticket
that I haven't covered?
Is there anyone here who
bought the lottery ticket
expecting to win, like, you
were putting all your hopes
and dreams on that?
Probably not.
So there's this belief--
another conventional belief
is that playing the
lottery is not rational.
And I think investing
your life savings
in playing the lottery
is not rational for sure.
But most of us, when we
buy the Powerball ticket
for a small amount of money,
we don't really expect to win.
We're not crushed when
it doesn't happen.
We're investing in a dream.
We're spending a few dollars
to have this little fantasy
of what would life be like
if I won the billion dollars
or whatever it was?
And then it's OK.
We kind of go on.
So the thing about
the lottery is,
the lottery is not hackable.
There's nothing we can do.
There's no tips.
There's no tricks, nothing we
can do to increase our odds.
It's a completely
randomized game.
But the career
lottery is hackable.
There are things we can do.
There are strategies
we can learn.
There are things
that we can adopt.
There's actions that we can
take that will improve our odds,
that will kind of increase
our chances of success
as we choose it, that
will help us find better
working conditions, that
will help us have more joy,
more money, and more
flow in our life.
So there's this Steve Jobs
quote that some of you
probably have heard in
thinking about life purpose
and thinking about the work
that you were born to do.
He said, "You can't connect
the dots looking forward.
You can only connect
them looking backward.
And you have to trust
that the dots will somehow
connect in your future."
I
And I like that
quote, but I think
it's not just about trusting.
It's not just about
being a passive observer
in this process.
It's about taking
strategic action.
It's about
understanding, OK, how
can I find joy, money,
and flow in my life?
How can I have more
days that matter?
How can I build out
that streak in my life?
What are the ideal
working conditions for me?
How can I do my best work?
How can I create more
security for myself
so that I can be
a better employee,
but also continue to invest
in myself for the future,
because no one will ever
care about my career
more than I will.
How can I truly understand, OK,
what is this thing out there?
And there's more than
one path, but how can I
go down different paths?
How can I do that?
And so it's not just
about passively observing.
It's about making
active decisions
and building a bridge
from one dot to another.
So we talked about
joy, money, flow.
We talked about how I
think everyone should learn
to think entrepreneurially
even if you don't
want to be an entrepreneur.
That's the whole concept
of the side hustle,
creating more
confidence and security.
If you are a specialized
expert in something,
which probably some of
you are, that's wonderful.
But if you're good at
a few different things,
that's also OK,
and people can be
successful in more than one way.
And if something
isn't working, then I
think you should stop doing it.
So I am super happy and honored
and excited to come back
to Google for my fourth visit.
I'll look forward to going
to the other 64, 66 locations
that you mentioned.
And if you remember only
one thing from this time
that we've shared,
you might remember
that there's a very high
percentage of pilots here
in this audience, or at
least aspirational pilots.
You might remember that the
lottery is not hackable,
the career lottery is.
But I would say if you
only remember one thing,
remember that it's
OK to make mistakes.
And not just is it
OK to make mistakes,
but the mistakes can
actually inform our thinking.
The mistakes can be beneficial.
They can help us to
make better decisions
as we go down different paths.
So making active choices is
almost always a good decision
even if we make
the wrong choice.
So if there is one thing
that you are meant to do
or born to do, I hope
that you do everything
you can to find that or discover
it or create it and bring it
into light, make it
happen for yourself.
And I hope you win the lottery.
Thank you, Google.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: If anybody
has any questions,
I'll bring around
the microphone.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Chris.
Thanks for being here.
My name's [INAUDIBLE].
You mentioned the
word success and you
said it means different
things to different people.
I'm curious, you've
obviously described
what success kind of is to
you, the three parts to that.
But if you're thinking of
the word success, who are
some people that you think of?
And why do you think
they're successful?
And what makes them successful
outside of just those three
things, or it could
those three things?
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Sure, sure.
I mean, I think those are
descriptors of success.
Those are qualities.
Those aren't necessarily,
this is what success is.
So I guess I think
for myself, and what
I see in a lot of other
people-- and perhaps some people
will relate to this,
maybe not everyone--
but I think of success
as continuously
improving your circumstances.
We're all on a journey.
We've all had circumstance and
luck and fortune in some ways
that have led us to we are.
We've all had privilege
that's affected our lives
and given us opportunities
that others don't have.
But yet we've also kind
of made choices as well.
And so when I look at people
that have influenced me,
or people in my
community, I guess
what I see is they're
striving, essentially.
And the previous book
that you mentioned,
"The Happiness of Pursuit," it
was very much about striving.
It was about looking at this
concept of going on a quest,
whether a physical
quest like I did,
with going to every
country, or lots
of people that did
other kinds of quests,
academic quests, different
kinds of things, explorations.
And there was this
quality of striving in it.
There was this
quality of, here's
the thing I'm reaching toward.
It's bigger than me.
It's going to require
something of me.
I'm going to be
changed through it.
So I think that is
an important factor.
AUDIENCE: And is
there any person
that you can think of that
you think embodies that?
I know you've mentioned a few.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Sure.
You know, I don't think of a
lot of-- I mentioned a couple
celebrities.
But I try to be really
careful in the books and all
of my work.
For the most part, I actually
don't look at celebrities.
I don't look at famous people.
I can't say, here
are give people
that I think are
successful, because what
I'm trying to do is look at
a lot of different people
representative of
the population,
and so that if
you read the book,
you're able to say,
OK, maybe I don't
identify with this
person's story,
but I identify with this one.
I'm not just reading
the author's story.
some famous person.
I'm reading all these
different people.
So I don't really
think of one person.
I think of a lot of people.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Chris.
My name's Michele.
So amongst all the
people that you've
spoken to throughout your career
and researching this book, lots
of creative people, they've
gone down different paths
and then pivoted.
I'm interested to know
about the value of intuition
in people's decision making
or your own, any insights
you can offer.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Yeah.
That's a great question.
I feel like maybe you have some
insider opinion of your own
to share as well.
So I do very much believe in
the value of intuition or gut
thinking.
And I think it comes in
in particular use when
we come to these choices of,
OK, I could go left or right,
and maybe I've already
done this analysis.
I've done as much fact-based,
objective-based analysis
that I could and I
still can't decide.
That's why I think it's
helpful to ask things like,
what gives you energy?
What drains your energy?
It sounds kind of
woo-woo but it's not.
A very practical question.
You can really look and
identify, OK, I did this.
I did this.
This is how it makes me feel.
If you come to that choice,
that question itself,
how does this make me feel?
If I think about this,
if I think about this.
And you have to kind of separate
the positive and negative
qualities of those
things, because you
might say, this choice, I'm
actually kind of afraid of it.
But that could be a good thing.
It can be, I'm afraid of it
because it sounds so big,
it sounds so challenging.
When I thought about
the travel quest,
I didn't begin that travel
quest at country number two.
I had been traveling
for a long time.
I loved traveling.
I lived in Africa.
And after I'd been to,
like, 70 countries,
it was like, what if I try to go
to every country in the world?
Wow, that really scares me, but
I'm also kind of drawn to it.
And so I feel like that's
where intuition comes in.
It may not give you
all the answers,
but as you kind of
come close to things,
then it can guide
you a little bit.
And I think I saw
that from the people
that I looked at in
the book as well.
There was a woman in
Mississauga, Ontario
who became the first female
firefighter in Ontario
23 years ago.
And obviously at
the time, that felt
like of an exclusionary field.
She was also very
short, short in stature,
so she was kind of the opposite
of what you would think
is a stereotypical firefighter.
But she had this
vision and she's
like, I really want to do it.
And so she decoded the process.
And so then she went into
this logical pursuit of it,
like what do I need to achieve?
What are the licenses?
What are the training?
What are the skills?
But before she did
that, it was kind
of an intuition-based
decision like,
I like that, that sounds crazy.
I want to do it.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I'm sort of curious
about your country quest.
Did you literally go to every
country, including North Korea?
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: I literally
went to every country.
It was an 11-year journey.
I wasn't traveling
continuously for 11 years,
but was this 11-year pursuit.
It was a process of decoding
and figuring out, OK,
what are the challenges?
North Korea is actually not one
of the most difficult countries
to go to.
People think of
North Korea and Cuba
and places like that--
well, Cuba is easy now,
but it wasn't until a few
years ago for Americans.
The countries that had
the more challenges with
were more Visa issues,
countries like Sudan,
like Yemen, couple of
other African countries.
I got deported when
I went to Eritrea.
So I don't have a
desire to go back there.
But most places I went
it was totally fine.
I had a wonderful experience.
It was a transformative act.
And people sometimes
ask how much time
do I spend in each country.
I lived in Liberia for a year.
I lived in the
Philippines for two years.
Some places I would
be for a month,
some places a couple of weeks.
And there were some countries
that were relatively brief,
one or two days or something.
And I don't pretend to be an
expert on the entire world
or something.
For me, I was
interested in the quest.
I was interested
in the act of, what
is it like to pursue this
dream and follow it logically?
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Chris,
I have a question.
Some of us have
people in our lives
that we could see could benefit
from something like this, kind
of going through this exercise.
But they may not have
the self-awareness
to know that they
necessarily need it.
I'm just curious
where and how you--
you've probably
come across people
like that that you
might want to nudge.
How would you go
about doing that?
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: I think
it's very hard to do that.
I think it's very hard
to say to someone, hey,
you need this thing.
Maybe there's a way to do it.
I would just say,
me personally, I'm
not in the business of
being an evangelist.
I'm not like a
door-to-door salesman.
You can be a door-to-door vacuum
cleaner salesman or saleswoman
and eventually succeed.
If you knock on enough
doors, someone's
going to buy that
vacuum cleaner,
but how much rejection
are you going
to go through along the way?
So personally, I'm much
more of a recruiter.
I'm like, here are these ideas.
People kind of come to
them when they're ready.
So sometimes I do these book
signings, and parents often
come to me and say,
my son or my daughter
really needs to read this book,
so I'm going to give it to them
so they read it.
And I'm like, I'm not sure
how that's going to work.
I'm not sure how
that's going to go.
Maybe one helpful thing is,
you used the word nudge,
so that's good.
Maybe it's like, how
can you be a role model
without being a role model?
How can you be a mentor
without being a mentor?
How can you help people
see what's possible?
That's a good thing.
Help people see
there's an opportunity,
there's a possibility,
there is more to life.
There is this available to
you, but it's here for you
when you're ready.
There are tools and
resources when you're ready.
And then they come to
it when they want to.
MALE SPEAKER: I think we've
got time for one more question.
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned briefly
a 14-question questionnaire
which you fill it
out, and that gives
you-- what's the basis for it?
What did you base it on?
Is it Myers-Brigg?
Is it any kind of
personality test?
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: No, it's
not based on Myers-Brigg.
It's based on all the work
that we did for the book.
I did it here with
Talia, my editor.
So we had spent a
long period of time
with all of the interviews.
And then I start from
a very large pool
of people with some introductory
interviews and surveys.
Then I choose a smaller circle
and do more detailed interviews
and surveys.
And then for the
people who are actually
in the book, at
that point I'm kind
of choosing representative
stories to ensure it's
diverse, to ensure that it's
hitting different points.
So as for the quiz itself,
as we learned things
about working conditions, as
we developed this model of joy,
money, flow, as we developed
other exercises in the book--
there's a number
of them-- that's
kind of how the quiz came to be.
And we then designed
personality types based
on all the research we had
done that said, OK, if you like
to work in this
manner, then here's
the ideal working
environment for you.
And again, you may not
have 100% autonomy--
you can't choose everything--
but you should be aware
that this is who you are.
You should be aware
of that whenever
you can create this
kind of environment,
then they'll thrive in that.
So if you take the quiz, let me
know if you like it or if you
don't.
AUDIENCE: Original research?
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU:
Original research, yes.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
Let's give another round
of applause to Chris.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]